bonjour nadège alors la colère sociale
gronde de nouveau un peu partout en
france
absolument après plusieurs journées
d'actions au cours du mois de janvier
le mouvement se poursuit avec un nouveau
temps fort de grèves
interprofessionnelles et de mobilisation
appel lancé par plusieurs syndicats la
cgt fsu solidaires ou encore une f1
mobilisation qui s'inscrit en défense de
l'emploi et des services publics
écrivent les syndicats dans un
communiqué les réformes successives
menées par les gouvernement facilite les
licenciements et les suppressions de
postes dans le privé comme dans le
public
là encore ni plan de relance ni plan de
rupture mais la poursuite du même
objectif néolibérale de profit à tout
prix au détriment de l'appareil
productif et des services publics
les syndicats estimaient en effet que le
plan de relance affichée par le
gouvernement n est en rien un plan de
rupture avec les politiques de casse de
l'emploi de pression sur les salaires et
sur les conditions de travail et
d'affaiblissement de la protection
sociale
il plonge une grande partie de la
population et notamment la jeunesse dans
la précarité et la pauvreté
par contre les gagnants sont bien
toujours les mêmes et ainsi les
entreprises les moins touchés par la
crise seront celles qui bénéficieront le
plus de baisses d'impôts alors manège
des syndicats qui déplorent une
augmentation de 175 milliards d'euros
des milliardaires français depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire absolument
alors que dit il les salariés et les
jeunes en subissent de plein fouet cette
crise sanitaire et qu'ils sont a laissé
à l'abandon par les pouvoirs publics
plus que jamais dit-il en cette période
de crise sanitaire alors avant leur
mobilisation les syndicats rappellent
des chiffres qu'il juge inacceptable 10
centimes d'euros ce qui correspond à
l'augmentation du taux horaire du smic
pour 2021 soit 14 euros de plus par mois
à zéro euro c'est aussi la non
augmentation pour toutes les professions
exposées au virus n 0 euros également
pour le nom d gel du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires depuis 11 ans et zéro
également un seul montant accordé par le
gouvernement à l'éducation nationale et
à l'enseignement supérieur pour faire
face à la crise qu vide
vous l'aurez compris lé syndicat réclame
donc un véritable plan de bataille en
véritable plan de relance pour que le
monde du travail et les jeunes puissent
sortir la tête de l'eau
les professionnels de la culture devrait
aussi se joindre aujourd'hui à cette
nouvelle journée de mobilisation le
monde de la culture qui subit aussi de
plein fouet cette crise sanitaire
puisque le secteur est à l'arrêt depuis
plusieurs mois à cause de la crise
sanitaire à plusieurs manifestations
sont prévues aux quatre coins de la
france à paris si elle commence à partir
de 14 heures au départ de la place de la
république et on suivra tout cela sur rt
france bien évidemment merci nadège
nadège abderrazak donc reporter pour
arte france